we woke up and my mama was all over the
place like yo we leaving like yo like
i'm not asking you i'm telling you
since the storm it seems like everybody
just moved on
in america especially during disaster
black children are not even the thought
have you ever like talked about this
before
no
i haven't
why are you dead
i don't know nobody they already asked
me
hurricane katrina caused one of the
biggest disbursements of black people in
history
after losing so much why wouldn't anyone
ask if we were okay
nobody ever asked the children how they
were doing
[Music]
friday i was at school walking the
hallways with my friends by monday i was
on top of [ __ ] roof
everything you consider as part of who
you are
was reduced to a trash bag
am i'm gonna die i don't know i just was
like i'm not supposed to be here
the new orleans that we knew was gone
[Music]
when i got back after katrina
i naively thought that everything was
going to be normal again
the film of community in new orleans is
different now your neighborhood was
crucial to who you were
what we knew to be true is gone
think about what that does to a
community it destabilizes it
i feel like nobody should be that young
going through [ __ ] like that
they're at home and they don't feel safe
what does that do to our children it
wreaks havoc on their well-being i can't
breathe
katrina is becoming a folktale and we're
the storytellers
resilience is when you still find a way
to have your head up and help yourself
sometimes i feel like resilience is used
as a tool
because they want people to think oh no
everything is okay these people are good
like they're strong look at how much
they've overcome
it's for me to say when i'm resilient
it's for me to say what is resilient
it's not for you
being able to tell my katrina story has
been part of my healing process
even though we are resilient we can
never get back what was
will lost grow
[Music]
you